[music]
at the train station in our place Kramatorsk
later than the tea station at the railway station by the
sound of people
[music]
if there were
rockets of people
now there were a lot of people killed a lot of
wounded ambulances police cars of the
fire brigade cars were burning nearby Well
it was just of course
What kind of help did you turn out to people I was on
in the car, so I immediately drove up to the
police and asked what kind of help they needed, they
said they need help to take the wounded away. I
undertook to get into the car of people who
were wounded, who had already been bandaged
, they provided first aid to the
hospital in the New World, these people,
what shrapnel wounds they all had.
character because
these are the elements that strike here,
that is, these elements
hit these people and, in principle,
almost 40 people died here
at the same time with these fragments
[music]
here you need to focus primarily
on the statement of the Ministry of Defense,
which
excludes the use of this missile
by our armed
our strength  e armed forces This type of missiles
are
also not used that there were no combat missions in
Kramatorsk and were not planned,
so the statement should be kept from this